well I got dumped I always get dumped
I'm a dumped I'm a dumper well that
attitude you go into the r like you're
going to dump me one day is everything
okay do you hate me do you not want to
be with me are you thinking that maybe
you don't want to be together and he's
like yes I don't want to be together and
I'm like what
what thank you to our sponsor prize
picks go to prize.com tr Tuesday and use
code trash Tuesday for a first deposit
match up to $10000 that's prize.com TR
Tuesday and use code trash Tuesday for a
first deposit match up to $100 prize
picks daily fantasy sports Made Easy
stop wasting money on things you don't
use cancel your unwanted subscriptions
and manage your money the easy way by
going to Rocket money.com Tuesday that's
rocket
money.com Tuesday rocket
money.com Tuesday hi slugs my tour is
coming to an end but there's a couple
dates left on November 16th I'll be in
Irvine at the Irvine Improv and also
towards the end of November I'm adding
some special small New York dates so if
you missed me this summer I cannot wait
to see you and you can get tickets to
all of those at Esther on ice.com hi
guys um I'm so excited I am on the road
forever and always uh come see me I love
the meet and greets I love meeting you
guys it's been so awesome I'm going to
be in San Jose at The Improv November
17th and 18th it's going to be so
freaking fun I have Lizzie cooperman
coming with me so check that out I'm
going to be in Houston Texas Edmonton
Alberta and jackonville Florida go to
Annie letter.com shows to check it
out all right welcome to trash Tuesday
we have our friend H's podcaster and
comedian
Jens in from New York hopefully we can
keep her I feel like we have a better
shot of keeping her in La than most she
lives in New York that's so cool and
glamorous did you not know that no W
also by the way when Esther was there
her fiance was working on a show and had
like a really nice place she had like a
very good life I did have like a really
great she had a life in New York that I
have never lived we had a thre Monon
like luxurious New York stay in SoHo and
I'm I realize now that that's not what
it would be like if I went I definitely
have an idealized version of what newor
I live two other dudes who stink they
Comics they're Comics I'm moving out
when as soon as I get back tomorrow I'm
mov are they sad or they don't care
they're sad we're all sad and we've
lived together a long time that sounds
fun you know I used to live with uh with
micro and Dan St Germaine you lived with
Chris and Mike at the same time yeah but
Chris really only stayed with us for one
night and stayed at his mom's house the
wow that's a lot of autistic gay people
in one room isn't it crazy yeah that's
crazy I never got to live with a bunch
of guys this sounds really fun it's the
best cuz you also get treated like if
you're in the bathroom they're like
don't even go near it like that's hers
like you are queen well I don't know if
that was my
experence mine was living with Mike I
was living with Mike ran where like he
was just making booger taking boogers
making like you got to stop it's the
real truth you got stop it's the truth
he did not he was making mountains of
boogers it's he's not do you mean
mountains of boogers stop done well I
don't know I don't know what to say he
made I don't know he has a beautiful
wife and a child I don't know how it
happened that is it's getting worse do
mean then there was a lot of there were
a lot of conversations that were like
Dan would be like Annie we got to we got
to tell Mike he can't he doesn't know
how to wash dishes they're not good
enough but I'm like both of them were
like adding stuff to the I'm like every
time they'd watch them it'd be like
grosser I was just like I'm going to
just get take out and never touch these
dishes when you live with men my fear
would be that that there would never be
toilet paper do you ever run out of
toilet paper we have toilet paper
mountain in our bathroom so I got like a
big wicker basket and it just always has
a mountain of she just knew I'm toilet
paper I'm the bad person so I have OCD
so I wipe my butthole is probably
bleeding currently cuz I wipe until if I
don't see blood it's not clean why
aren't you using wet get a b day do you
want to get into this right now bedet
first of all it just sprays your
butthole it doesn't unless it has a
chisel attach to it no you need a dry
it's like if you spackle you need a
sandpaper on the Spackle you can't just
wet it mush it around you need to chafe
off the flesh I'm imagining like cocking
your [__] shut just having that would
be great that would be ideal I don't
understand I you cannot get clean with
dry you seem like you might have like a
duty ass no not at all are you kidding
have you ever had a little Duty Bus we
all know that you WIP with you the
vagina take the vagina juices and use
that on the [__] we all do it no she
does the opposite we all do it we've
been through this so that's true look
you never know when a man is going to
want to eat your ass and you want to be
present into the butt St I I'm not into
it it just might happen it just might
happen to me tickle torture that happens
to her actually does she not look like
the most tickle tortur of person you
looks so pretty really the lighting you
look pretty too it's the lighting I like
your glasses I used to wear um the ones
that you would take I think for was it
for shooting and everyone was like I
remember Joey Diaz stopping me in the he
was like stop wearing this stuff I got
these at a dollar store I wear them on
podcasts because the the lights are very
bright sometimes I like that you can
solve your problems at the dollar store
yeah that's like really not many people
can not to bring up Dan St Germaine
again but I'm having a dollar store
memory I was I went to there was a
dollar store around our neighborhood and
I went in to get like you don't say
someone returning something at the
Dollar Store like this phone charger
doesn't work and I was Dan St jman and I
was like Dan oh wow it was so psychotic
it was like do you need to borrow a
dollar what are you doing isn't it crazy
when you have that moment where you're
like whoever this person is is [__]
psychotic and oh not only they're my
friend I live with them no or I look in
the mirror and it's me that's often I
checked out a guy the other day and I
was like that's the hottest man I've
ever seen I want to be with him for the
rest of my life and he turned and it was
my roommate oh yeah and I was likees
thisan no no no he we're just we're so
close but he got like a new sweater
who's this man with us this is my my
friend Duncan is here we've been friends
a long time okay Duncan do you have a
crush on her or dun we both we well
forever I have we have a crush on
everybody oh I
like no but I there's a beauty to it I
have a million hot male friends none of
which I date really I'm actually
currently low on single males in my life
like normally I'm really good at setting
people up or positive setup my mom was
good she like like put people together
that got married I also think it's a
numbers game it's like put people on
dates if it doesn't work who cares like
it's good sometimes yeah putting people
on dates is a nice thing to do my
friends never do this nobody ever does
this anymore I love this I'm really low
on single Jewish men and even just
single regular men more well Jews are in
they're being they they're beloved right
now in the in the single woman Community
yeah once you get into your 30s you're
like I want somebody smart funny capable
and you lose yeah and yeah uncut and you
lose all the necessity for like for like
handy rustic all of that goes away in
your 20s you're like that's I don't want
the idiot who can build a fire yeah and
also it's like the roofers are
married are married roers are married if
you had to guess how common it was for
new baby boys to be cut or not cut like
what percent I it's going down right
less cutting it's going down now it's
50/50 which I was shocked I thought it
was going to be on each penis they just
do
half that's they're like you
decide but like I would have thought it
was way less but I guess but I think it
was more before right no are we doing in
the world cuz I feel like other
countries don't this was just like one
doctor said it so it was like you're
like it was a Tik Tok I lost it I forgot
to save it I didn't finish it um no but
a doctor said that and I was like whoa I
believe in the uncut gem yeah little you
got a little BV though little it's a
little more a little more you got a
little more risk if he's like an ape I
mean people can clean their think of our
vaginas we clean those
those I like you said a Verina think
about the vgina that's my lesbian mom's
talking that's your vagina if I was a
guy and I was uncut I would have died at
three like from back to yeah I'm so
unclean is there even though I just said
but Dy butt I said there could be Dy
butt I just said I just inquired I don't
say anything I let you take it and you
you been in the bathroom with girls who
do Coke and then they [__] and you see
them wipe and you're like that was one
pass maybe two there's no way you don't
have I thought we were talking about the
co like something getting connected but
it was just that you were in the you
when you're always when girls I was like
what are they like wiping and then
they're like like throwing their
fingernails well they're always like
they'll go into the bathroom and then
they'll do Coke and then they're like oh
my God I have to [__] cuz they have Coke
shits and then you see them [__] and
then they're talking to you manically
about whatever some like you know which
which type of what do you call it em emj
they are whatever the [__] what whatever
Myers brg personality they are and then
they go and WIP dropped a few earlier
and then they wipe and you're like that
was one pass dude that was one pass
there's no way you're done but you're
not close enough to say anything you've
also done half their Coke you're why am
I watching you [__] why does this have
to be a part of I want to be in the coke
bathroom I've never been it sounds fun
it sucks it sucks it's like really scary
cuz I don't do Coke anymore but I used
to do a lot so now it's like a really
scary place now you're like are you guys
okay yeah now they trap you and they're
like can we we I just want to talk to
you what's going on with you and your
dad I like that a lot it's really
scary's like this is my dream like H how
but how did you stop I feel like that's
a hard thing to stop and you seem so
confident you're like it's it's over oh
because here's what happens you if you
have like a bipolar or [__] up alien
brain between bumps of coke you Plum it
and you can tell if you're doing coke
with people there are some people who
are like sure I'll take another bump and
then there are some people who are like
hey do we need to call somebody to get
more I I'm not able to we're just gonna
need to get it down on the and I was
that person and I was dating a dude at
the time who wasn't like that showed you
more how crazy you are right and I was
like this is cuz between bumps if you
have the whatever serotonin brain the
bad one it feels like you're like I will
kill myself if I don't get another bump
there's no other way to go I just always
felt like this is my take on coke it's
just not good so then you're always
trying to get more CU you're like when
does this get good oh yeah for me it's
so good and then it plummets into bad
I've never yeah I've always been like I
actually learned a similar lesson from
my partner my boyfriend whatever you
call him Dave you're engaged engaged for
years over um what is it called the way
he eats french fries versus how I eat
french fries like I never knew that you
could just like not finish them or that
you could just not like have to like put
I'm sorry that you're in an abusive
relationship that's so [__]
up I'll never forget that for some was
like you didn't finish your fries he's
not skinny like I I don't I don't know
what you're like do not accuse me of
dating a skinny man do not not Esther I
the other day every day when Todd orders
food or whatever he'll leave like his he
doesn't finish I always finish my food
not because I'm worried about like my
parents did not tell me to finish my we
just all finished everything yeah he'll
leave like you know half I just will
finish yeah yeah yeah there's no like it
wasn't for anyone else yeah it was just
okay so he leaves like half like a pasta
or something and I he'll catch me just
eating it like cold off the thing and he
goes do you have any respect for
yourself and I'm like what does I'm not
even thinking right now you're not there
I'm I'm I'm in a mode right now I'm in
beast mode right now okay we call it
this is my this is my workout no offense
to your friend but we call it Duncan
Dimension because that's my parents
obese dog who passed away last year but
like Dave was like oh you're in Duncan
Dimension right now cuz I'm just like
you know eating I'm not present I'm not
there but he's like he up di is great
Duncan has a dimension my friend Duncan
who's over there he has dementia has
yeah but he he would call me and be like
dude I [__] up last night and I'd be
like what and he'd be like I ate I ate
like a a whole box of cereal and I was
like that's crazy and he was like no no
no but I would go dip it into peanut
butter dip it into cereal eat it and I
was like I would be a different person
like I would W up he ate the whole box
you're like no no I ate the cardboard it
was really he was like I I I ate the box
and half a jar of peanut butter I I was
like that would I would be dead over for
sure hung over the next I would be
constipated for 6 weeks yes oh my God
Queen right yes I don't I never [__]
I've been [__] a lot since the
breakup that's sick which I want to talk
about well drama drama well I got dumped
I always get dumped I'm a dumped I'm a
dumper that attitude you go into the r
like you're going to dump me one day I
get dumped dog I get straight up dropped
well it was on and off it was we break
up like once a month yeah you said he
dumps you once a month yeah and how long
is the when did it start 2 years years
ago almost years ago do your friends
like him some of them don't know him
okay yeah Duncan's never met him it's
not Duncan oh he would know we like
could you imagine if it was Duncan no
he's just like a hyper he's a hyper he
just like I'm very uh chaotic and very
like is something wrong is everything
okay do you hate me do you not want to
be with me are you thinking that maybe
you don't want to be together and he's
like yes I don't want to be together and
I'm like
what what and then we like I had no clue
I was blindsided but if a guy's dumping
you once a month why are are you taking
him back every time you know when you
have a dream and your your best friend
in the dream is like I hate you and then
you wake up and it feels so good that
they're still your best friend so when
somebody dumps you spontaneously like he
does where he's just like it's done I'm
so freaked out I'm so weird and then the
second he's like he gives yeah you're
like oh for a second there I thought the
world was [__] up and then you keep Jo
it I'm I get it but I'm getting upset at
this yes yes most people do it's
disturbing my mom is like my mom is like
every other she's like a very compelling
like avoidant autistic almost person and
she would just be like you're my
daughter today not tomorrow like that so
that's what I'm addicted to now I had no
like unconditional I don't even know
unconditional love is like disturbing to
me the thing is here's the
thing obviously we all just need
securely attached guys which I think we
found securely ATT cuz do you think they
securely attached like Beyond yeah but
you found him you got him young and
you're just dating somebody who is
you're so far out of his League that's
all that's going on and I would really
like you to stop calling that securely
attached fiance yeah that's great but
you are out of his league so even if he
was an avoidant guy he would never be
with you so funny but not true because
okay rip Matthew Perry he I just saw an
like watching interviews and stuff and
he said that he was this TV star dating
this movie star Julia Roberts and he was
so like anxious of whatever his issues
were he dumped her because he was so
afraid he knew she was so much higher up
that he was so afraid she was going to
dump him I am not dating down you don't
think it's dating down in with this I
done that before Oh my God you're not
dating down to you which is very sweet
you know when your friend is like oh
he's really secure I'm like he's he
wouldn't be secure if he was dating
somebody his age who's like struggling
you know what I mean like he is like
he's bringing don't you think he should
be secure he should be more anxious
because I guess I assume every man is
avoidant I do too I really mostly I me
aren't mostly but the one's I I know
some anxious guys really oh they never I
never I never dated them I'm friends
with them anxious guys are sweetie pie
Cutie Pies but I would never have but
you watch them doing what girls do you
know what I mean you watch them being
like too much can you read this text is
this text bad is it stupid that I said
this and you're like wow or like the
girl being like I need I need space and
then being like I'm just going to like
text her all day and you're like she
literally just said give me some she
just told you now do you have any
aspirations to be like cuz you you seem
very aware that this like cycle you're
in is not good you know why you're in it
too cuz it's like something about you
know your mom relationship with your mom
are you like I got to stop this are you
you're like life is fine and it doesn't
matter like what will I go back into it
yeah well that this is the scary like
Black Mirror of it all is every time it
ends I'm like I'm never going back there
and then time passes I get really
freaked out and then we see each other
and it's like what's up I've completely
forgotten that you destroyed my life I
missed you so much now okay so which
you're not alone this is like do he date
other people in between I don't ever
care to know you okay oh that's
impressive I will because I'm so jealous
that I will burn a house down but you
must not be that jealous you're not the
jealous type that's like what happened I
need to know everything um I know that I
I I I'm somebody who if I had a terminal
illness I would not want to know like
I'm like if you cheat on me just don't
[__] tell me very much like that like
if I was in an open when I've been in
open things I'm like do whatever you
want wrap it up do not ever let me find
out who it is this is impressive would
you be mad at her or would you be mad
are you mad at him it just would I it
would just become a it would just be
pain Loop you're not going through
anyone's phone [__] no when my friends
go through their boyfriend's phones I'm
like y That's nightmare you're going to
always find something [__] up I I mean
I accidentally have gone through Guys
phone like literally just looking for
just literally like did he save this
text of mine having no clue cuz I'm with
the person 24/7 and they're just fully
cheating on me and I'm like I canot
believe I just found that out like just
fully shocked like oh my God never going
in with that intent fully like they're
in a relationship with somebody else
yeah you're like oh this person just met
your parents you're like what how did
they meet your parents I'm with you
every day do you want to have some kind
of a plan in place to prevent going back
or you're not thinking about it get the
get the I have block everything's
blocked and I have a therapist now and
yes I'm thinking about doing there's
like this Retreat that you can go to for
a few days that deals with the the the
cycle attachment cycle or whatever
you're going to go on a retreat I might
go is a drug [__] each other what it is
a I believe it is a drug addiction it is
a drug addiction I have someone in my
life that I'm very close with that is in
a similar thing but I think is probably
worse
um where like they keep going back to
this person that keeps not choosing them
and does not but like they're having sex
and stuff and but she's in love with him
and clearly he's in love with someone
else know you're talking about what I
think I know you're talking you don't oh
I don't okay it's B it but it's
oh but like I always I'm like you're
dealing with a slot machine sometimes
you press the lover and he likes you and
sometimes he doesn't and you're addicted
slots are so F I was in Vegas this
weekend and I saw people sitting it's
like and you just press the button
looking judge I'm not got come with the
queen I have my own slot
issues what you haven't said you haven't
had the most fun you can have on a slot
machine sitting next to me on one of
those double love oh my God Esther I
would love to have that would actually
be so entertaining playing like the
karate kid but here's the thing that's
the second time I've heard that movie
today it's a core you kind of give me a
Vibe I want to talk to about Kate kid
really I just want to break it out I
didn't mean to but now that I'm saying
that but I I do I think that it's like a
you know you get like used to this
belief about yourself where it's like oh
I'm not the chosen one or whatever so
then you just go back to the thing
that's going to keep I don't think
everybody gets to be the chosen one
that's the other thing is I'm like if
you want to be with a very special
person they're going to leave you all
the time that's so crazy I know but that
is I'm just saying like the Lucid back
of my mind would you be the special
person
I'm I'm special but like if I'm like
what do this person do well the humor
they're funny are they a comedian they
are a person who exists in the world oh
they're funny they make you laugh you
have fun together s yeah and when it's
good it's super good and you never know
when it's just going to turn you admire
them which makes it even better um I
admire their humor yeah they're just
very intriguing to me they're very stoic
they're not I I can it I also my
favorite thing is to be like please
please please love me please please and
the second that turns on me and
somebody's like love me I it's like
roling so I love being like please
please and that's when I feel I have the
most energy is when I'm fighting you the
youngest sibling I'm the youngest and I
was also had bad bad bad NE neglection
selection you know what do you mean it
just was I just was not like a neglected
not selected I was neglected not
selected yeah totally I um I Heard on
your special you talk about you call
like your sister a and stuff she went
through the program that I'm going to go
through and now she kind of rules really
yeah this I like this used to sock and
now she we like hung out the other day
and it was chill now this Retreat is
like they give you like smoothies and
they basically are like they make you
look into the eye of the devil they make
you like look at what happened to you as
a child and really face it I guess and I
for years have been like gay that's dumb
who cares I am what I am like someone
going to dress up like a lesbian and
have you like yell at them like through
your mom I don't know but that would be
I have no idea my sister hasn't
disclaimed like the whole thing okay I
like that too where she's like not going
to give it away she's like just do it
and she came out and was like she before
she had this like TJ Maxx angry [__]
Vibe and now she has this like chill
like even her house has like watercolors
that for the kid is out now and like
it's less like why did you put that
there don't put that and I'm like oh I'm
going to do this [__] now okay when
you're on the on cycle with this guy
yeah is it affecting your career are you
writing the same amount or you not yeah
I have missed gigs I have been I have
gone up I mean I literally called Duncan
the other day and was like I have to
record a podcast in 5 minutes and I'm
hyperventilated and I had to like get it
together and there's an entire podcast
right now where we had Jeremiah on where
I'm just you can just see tears coming
behind my sungasses like what the freak
is going on yeah I've had in every
airport I've been dumped in so I'm like
I'll go to the LA airport and be like I
don't hear that so every weekend is
Tainted by I hate this for you I hate
this but it's also it's also I the thing
that you have to remember is I am
choosing it so I am like yeah something
stable scares the [__] out of me okay
yes you are I see how you're saying that
you're choosing it but I also like and
maybe again this is like in the light of
Matthew Perry and like consuming all his
content and stuff like he I'm he's so
open about addiction and he's so open
about saying like this is a disease I
did not choose this and I'm just trying
to put all these puzzle pieces together
with this other person in my life in a
similar thing and I'm like maybe when
I'm begging her to stop going back to
this guy maybe I'm talking to a drug
addict who cannot it's definitely yeah I
almost killed my friend's cat over a guy
I was like anxiously attached to really
I was I forgot I was catting I was just
at this guy's house do you like me do
you like me do you like I like wouldn't
leave he wouldn't tell me to leave and I
wasn't going to I was just like waiting
it's crazy you lose sleep you lose you
start like you know you realize that
you've just like expedited an entire
amount of time because you've just been
obsessing about this one thing and to be
fair I'm like very obsessive compulsive
so it's not that if it's not that it's
something else but that's something else
could be comedy or exercise or taking
care of myself it definitely has a
negative impact when things are good I
crush on stage but that's like a tiny
are you trying to like fix him too like
his problems with commit to you like in
your head are you like it's a problem he
has that he can't every time he comes
back he's like I got it I got it now but
are you like cuz I had a guy where I was
like oh he just has these problems and I
can just fix them and then he'll see
that I'm like the best every time I
would try to do something cuz I knew I
was suffering like I knew I was like
sick at that moment with this like I did
feel sick I did feel like sick it's
mentally and so I would like go do like
breath work or yoga or go to a
meditation class and every time I would
have like a good feeling I'd be like I
got to show him this oh like I would go
to I would def want to you wanted him to
experience what you were experiencing
but I was like oh this will help him
like I it was like it was almost like
everything was set up so I didn't have
to like heal whatever was happening to
me and it was like I was using him to
like project onto him it doesn't sound
exactly the same to what you're going
yeah mine is more like if I if I just
stay myself he'll eventually realize
that life is better with me around so
then I would show up and be like I have
period cramps and feel like I'm dying
and have the flu but I'm gonna be my
best self so you see and then I would
just like exhaust myself and trying to
be and then I just gave that up and I
was like whatever I'm just going to be
myself and things were good for a while
but eventually when his like avoidant
thing and he was like I don't know if I
want to do to that's when I'm like I
need reassurance and he'd be like I
can't give it to you and I'd be like I'm
freaking out and he'd be like that's
okay we can break up and I'm like I
don't want to do that no I know and they
do the thing where they don't give you
what you want at all and they're just
like but I told you the truth and you're
like but why do you keep getting back
with me I also am anxious avoid it and
so like I'll when ever I'm you know
feeling like not getting the connection
I want with every guy I've ever been
with I'm like maybe we should break up
and then those few times where they
they're like okay that happened early on
with Dave and I think I've told you this
I was like no no no no wait wait like
immediately I was like no no no and he
was like okay fine I have so many so
many moments where I'm like I'm leaving
and then I'm slowly walking to the door
and I'm like oh my God I left my I left
my did you run away when you were a kid
and oh and no one noticed yeah I so
little it's hard now were you actually
raised do you have two moms or three I
have it's so crazy my mom and my dad we
need to book the studio another three
hours today we need to extend one for
each mother it's a lot I mean it's like
Technic it's like two and a stepmom so
it's like my mom was married to my dad
uh they met playing rugby shock her that
she's gay um they had a my mom was
racket ball racket ball very gay they
had a construction business together
they split up and then when when did
they split up I was two okay so it was
her fault so it was my fault yes it was
it really I mean it wasn't but they were
going to so funny that you really do
think it is your fault I mean no you
really really do of but you have a
sibling it's the sibling's fault too
it's my Stoner dad's fault he smoked
weed constantly and wanted like a farm
life and my mom was like I don't want to
be a farm she was like I want [__] yeah
and then she left she still dated men
and then she met Michelle who became
Michelle was like the first introduction
of like oh that's what like a mom is a
mom yeah and I was like a thousand PB M
goth disgusting you know self Cuts
everywhere their I thought they did too
and I was like I will kill myself I was
like that is crazy we got one ready for
you yeah they don't exist they've all
been burnt in a with me I have some
pictures that don't exist of myself too
so I feel yeah yeah that's the closest I
can get to understanding when people are
like it's my dead name I'm like oh yeah
I have one of yeah I've always been
really cute one time I showed I showed
Dave a picture of me in college and I
was like I go look at my cousin don't we
look so much alike he's like yeah you
guys do and I'm like that's me you
[__] but I was unrecognizable my God
he must be like he's in hell with you
just these little twists and turns and
tricks he doesn't actually get in
trouble it's like you know what I mean
like my tricks are such jokes that
that's my twin brother why were you a
hot Sledge I was hot slot I was I was 14
in [__] off but see then there's like
that when I was 14 15 maybe 15 you look
like an adult I know they really did
adult me fast like Britney Spear you
look like a Maxim model something what
were you doing uh that was the your I
was getting your brother's just getting
hard the poor thing I mean that's [__]
up look up pictures of me in new girl
you don't look bad I just like this was
like I was on my way out of my college
look cute she looks so cute look really
cute I don't know you guys she looks
like Stella before her second
divorce Stella is our producer going
through her second divorce I've seen you
talk about this a little bit and I want
to ask you about it that you kind of
have this like Life Theory this
hypothesis that like being a woman is
bad oh yes yes yes and I want to know
what you mean like what's that about um
yeah so I'm working so like the whole
hour that I'm about to record here
pretty soon is about how you just didn't
know it's so how you already have one I
know sick to my stomach I know I'm sorry
she already has a new one because I'm
depressed yeah she get she's getting
dumped every once mon bro I'm getting
dumped and and I so yeah the whole hour
I'm working on is how like being a woman
is just like inherently like it just
does suck and it's all about you know
like how everybody has always been like
you're a lesbian you're a lesbian I'm
like I'm not this is actually what a
woman would look like if they weren't
insane I mean which sounds insane cuz
I'm insane but so it's like a lot of cuz
I used to be a contractor and stuff and
people are like oh you're like a dude
and I'm like no men should or women
should be like dudes like we do
everything you know what I mean like we
have all of the and I'm talking about
how like our entire like I just think
it's crazy that like we get our like our
whole psyche is built around a cycle and
then we get and then we get shamed for
being people who like Loop and obsess
and are crazy and I'm like yeah it sucks
to be trapped in an endless cycle we
don't get to escape it [__] [__]
ER you know making that realization the
past few years that it's none of this is
all out of our control it's like all
based on your mood is just what day of
your cycle are you on and it's also when
you feel it you're like this is truth
like how I'm feeling totally yeah and
you don't want to say like have you in
the relationship where the guys are like
are you on your period and you're like
you like just started spotting but
you're like no yeah like I might have to
hide my period from him for one full
week like you're like that's not what it
is I'm actually really pissed at you and
you are pissed they are being a [__]
[__] it's like I'm just not I'm not
like in the part of my cycle where I can
refrain from being pissed at you for
being an [__] right now and that's
what my friend says she goes she she
read some article that was basically
from this doctor who was like you know
what you are a no for before your period
like you know what is your boundary is
and the rest of the month you're kind of
just like able to break that boundary so
it's not like you're like it's not like
you're a different person being like I
don't like when you do this you're just
like I now have the courage because I'm
at my level it's like if you're dating
somebody who smokes weed all the time
and you finally you get your period and
you're like dude you're [__] high all
the time it's not like the next week
you're like I Love
Weed you know you're like I do that does
bother me you know Esther was like it's
I just want to get old so I don't get my
per like there's metapa is like I think
way worse is that true I was just
thinking about that escape plan that I
have or just like get the uterus after I
think when once you're like through
menopause I think you're I think that
rules right okay I have all of the
tricks of the trade to because I want to
be like I I think being a man is so sick
like they just live linearly like they
just are like this that's how they view
things compartmentalize it's very yeah
they compartmentalize they move it over
here they're moving forward they're
looking they're searching they're
they're way more able to be in the
moment because that's like what their
biology says whereas ours is like
protect which is great because it means
that if I'm your friend I will truly be
we I have so much easier for me to be a
friend than it is for a guy in your life
like it they have to learn that but that
sounds like a burden for you but it
feels good cuz like we'll probably when
they will die they will we'll have a
gaggle of women about around us being
like 1 2 three die and they'll be alone
so it is there are good parts of it and
it's also Parts where it's like we the
the feeling that you get is probably
there are probably more Vivid colors at
times and all this [__] but I have like
tried to train it so my cycle is as
close to a man's like right before my
period the the Prozac goes up yeah
anything that yeah wait you guys are
doing that like I yeah my psychiatrist
she's amazing she gives she's like you
should take an extra 10 milligram when
you're when you have your period yeah
hell yeah I take an extra I didn't know
you could like bottle yeah I double it
and now do you smoke weed I don't smoke
weed I do weed would be good for me but
weed I get panic attacks I get I'm very
person who's like if there was a knife
sitting there it would like bother I
would be constantly wondering if I was
just going to stab my leg with it so
when I smoke weed I'm like what if I bit
my tongue off right now what if I give
that a Goa okay we'll keep that away
from you yeah like airplanes if I'm next
to the emergency exit thing
problem problem but I think you it can't
open I think I heard that yeah there
actually was a guy recently who did open
it and I've never resonated with a
person more so funny I know and you know
he just did it like was just like they
asked him they're like why did you do it
and he goes I was feeling really anxious
and I was like buddy tell me about it
and he's just sitting in the chair like
this as the plane is like it's like wide
open he's like and I'm like yeah it is
interesting how few plane freakouts
there are and like that's now that
everyone's filming on their phone like
you know that we're seeing the ones that
are existing like we're seeing all of
them like the lady where is like the
that's no one's there like that's should
be happening all the time or just
somebody being like stop the plane stop
the plane pull over is like that's what
I'm always afraid of that I'm going to
freak out and be like dude you guys have
to land this or I'm going to have to
eject myself and then I end up getting
up so panicked I fainted on a plane one
time because I was panicked myself
luckily I'll just faint if I panic
enough I'll just no you faint a lot is
it embarrassing to wake up from a faint
or youed yeah cuz sometimes I sweat
through my clothes so much and I don't
know if I peed my pants or sweat through
my clothes so that's is it like seizure
style like you just come to and you're
like no it's like I drift everything
goes white I drift off and then I open
my eyes and they're like the plane is
landing and I'm like [__] I'm glad I
kept breathing and the person next to me
is like this and I'm like I'm sorry for
whatever I did sorry for whatever I did
but when you faint in public like do you
fall to the ground like do have do you
like faint no once you or know you're a
fainter you know when it's coming and
then you get yourself down and you like
the only time I fainted was at my dad's
like office party when I was 11 I was
huffing helium and I it was at an ice
skating ring so I was on ice skates and
I was just huffing the [__] out of
healing balloons and then all of a
sudden I was just like looking at skates
like I was on the ground looking yeah
that's passing out passing out rules
fainting is like you think you're going
to throw up everything gets white the
ringing in your ear goes and then you're
thought start racing so fast that you're
the only thing and the sweat starts
dripping and then the only thing you can
do is pray that you faint because you're
in such a hell and are we night sweaters
I mean yeah I mean I'm just in a puddle
of sweat I only when I'm sick but I love
it oh you would be so cute like a little
puddle I love waking up sweaty litt's
puddle she's so little cuz then you're
like oh that was productive like I
release toxin adorable I am night
sweating all the time and I was like oh
my God am I like going to be one of
these like early menopause [__] and
then I got test in the r no you're just
anxious it's anxiety yeah the the the
whole being a woman sucking thing also
have been asking a lot of men who've
seen the hour and they did say it
doesn't suck to watch it because it's
also very silly and disgusting or they
like it doesn't suck to be a woman no
they're like because I was like is this
hour only are women going to love this
and men and they're like no it's dis I
mean I talk about like cats being [__]
and stuff like there's but I am I am
like the hour is like you must oh wow
thank you so much are we going to deep
throw this or something are we going to
lizo me now um yeah you we're going to
fire you can't be on the tour oh I
because of we've put these in our
vaginas oh okay okay but if I eat it I
now do you think she had unpeeled it it
was peeled I think that it went into
somebody's vagina it came out and lizo
was like eat that [__] and she was like
what and she was like seriously eat it
and I think that she meant peel it and
eat it yes which is nothing it's nothing
but it's also like it's also like
Testament to how crazy Fame is where you
get to a point where you're like and eat
it in front of me that's a little bit
like King
telling its servants yeah totally to do
I don't think I want it today do you
guys always eat a banana there probably
keeps your patreon numbers up you know
what I
mean I look I'm going to be honest I've
just been watching my brothers and my
boyfriends do fantasy sports and do all
I was like what are you guys doing and
then I realized there's money involved
it made Sports fun it's this is my
Taylor Swift okay this made me enjoy
sports this is like I'm in now it's so
fun go to prize.com Tuesday and use code
trash Tuesday for the first deposit
match up to $100 that's prize.com trash
Tuesday and use code trash Tuesday for a
first deposit match up to $100 just take
the money prize picks daily fantasy
sports Made Easy okay Esther and I
roleplay she is my business manager I
worry about you not checking your credit
card statements I worry about your
spending she worries about me but worry
no more because rocket money has me and
let me tell you something
I um did find once that I had two apple
IDs and I was oh no I was subscrib I was
subscribed to the same apps on twice
okay and did I know did I check anything
no but guess who told me rocket money
you guys rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps you lower your bills
all in one place with over 5 million
users in counting rocket money has
helped save customers and average of
$720 a year and 1 billion in total
savings so far and that was just my
accounts it has helped us both so much
they this is they set it up for us to
forget this is like set it up so you
sign up and then you forget about it
this is the move they go oh do your free
trial oh just one week you can do this
and I'm like always oh I'll cancel
tomorrow there's no tomorrow okay
there's never a tomorrow I never
remember stop wasting money on things
you don't use cancel your unwanted
subscriptions and manage your money the
easy way by going to Rocket money.com
/tr Tuesday that's rocket money.com sltr
Tuesday rocket money.com sltr
Tuesday would you rather have a partner
with a micro penis or a partner with a
huge member that you can't have sex with
anally and
vaginally
vaginally what and my jaw is going to be
able to take it yeah like you can I
think it's more what's their sex drive
are they wanting me to bang them all the
time time but it's tooo big cuz that is
not somebody had a bad time listen
sometimes it's a chore but so you can't
bang it or you're having sex with a
micropenis yeah I honestly just feel bad
for micropenises I think micropenises
are more likely to to kill us so I think
we need to just say we love micropenises
we're so happy you guys are here and
please don't buy pleas subscribe to the
patreon I don't necessarily have a
problem with that like I don't I don't
want to say too much cuz like it's from
a past relationship but oh my God it
like it's not that bad you had a
micropenis guy yeah I think so cuz
you're so small and I think you have a
micro vagina I think that they're good
at sex cuz they really care they're good
at eating [__] I think there's I think
there's things that that can be done and
that it's actually like totally
enjoyable I know that might seem crazy
if you're a big dick girly the question
is micro or zero penis micro or way too
large like can like hurts going in micro
is such an easy choice for me it's so
easy oh wow I do not feel that way way
too big is so fun because it's like it's
like a cold
plunge right where you're like I'm going
to [__] die dude at the end or like I
survived that it's just but that's what
I mean like where it's like cuz
obviously like a huge cock's fun but
it's like we're together forever yes I
got to every day I got to your [__]
going to get bigger because yeah all of
a sudden it's stop it fits and you go
whoops yeah but didn't shink but then
you have a kid it FL onto the floor well
did you ever use the diva cup yes when
they change sizes on you it's like you
turn 30 and they're like oh um either
you've had a kid or you're 30 and I was
like you're saying my 30-year-old vagina
is the same size as having a baby it's
so [__] up but I guess maybe I like
even when I'm watching porn and it's
like a big D I like have to turn it off
cuz I just
ow this is a three little bears thing
tiny girl says tiny you're like and I'm
like big dick but that doesn't mean just
been I've been in hell with a big dick
before I'm not trying to act like my
vagina I think our vaginas are all the
same size like I don't think it's like
that I think it's personal preference I
think mine is quite long I couldn't
touch the strings of my IUD oh I
couldn't either yeah oh you couldn't
yeah our cervic are high can you take a
big old hog get over here no yeah I like
the I think the pain is I think the pain
is no pain no gain you know yeah and
I've there are a couple dudes where I've
been like your dick is so big that like
this actually wouldn't be a good time
for me and imagining that dude and I
think there's something cool about being
like I can't I can't it's too much too
big it's too big as opposed to being
like throw it in or like having to like
like build them up like building up a
micro like having to be like no it's
okay and we just don't talk about it I
mean the microen I've had two
micropenises in my life okay and they
one didn't acknowledge it but was very
good at going like I mean he was just
immediately like being an excellent
mouth guy and then the other one like
acknowledged it so fast it was like
weird he was like it's okay imagine
let's do a demonstration okay I'm the
man imagine I'm the man and I have a
micro penis okay I can't imagine you not
have okay you're like easy okay like
imagine if I put my penis in in you and
even I couldn't feel it and even though
it's really tiny I'm just
like no but it's not like buping my CP
yeah man right now just there's things
like just look at my hips and what I'm
doing like tell me that you don't think
by the way he's climbing on me like man
is koala is he the same size The Way She
Moves so slowly and she's like just
imagine I'm the man he's like a
regularized man and he's climbing my leg
you're laying down in that they're great
the way she approached so gently it was
like a baby koala but it's like but are
you turned on at all 1 to 10 are you
turned on by me at all I'm I'm in like
analytical thoughts no I'm like trying
to think cuz I'm like zero it's it's a
negative but um no it was cute I tried
to grab your ass to make myself hard no
it's like okay so the the first guy I
hooked up with in college Who had who
very much worshipped me nice that was
like weird but um he was like kind of
tough because of it I think so he would
never have been like because it was
small yeah I think he was trying to be
more but it just was so it was like a
suction there was nothing suction I
didn't know what he was I think if he
had training if somebody a guy came like
my dick is Tiny But I have this sword
I'm going to [__] you with not a sword
but like a dildo and they were like I'm
going to lay it down don't worry about
this little guy he he's going to watch
and they were funny about it it's fine
but they wouldn't carry shame and that's
scary it was like a yeah it's like a
micro like he's there something yes you
guys that is what a microp penis is
it's like it was like two number two it
was like two number two pencil erasers
fused together I'm going to say microen
should become into ableist like it
should almost be called like we should
almost say tiny penises and then micro
is like saying somebody has like
cerebral py like you just wouldn't say
like yeah no it felt like this guy has
like a something like up with him give
me his penis and one night with you I
feel like you already have it having to
blow a little penis just no it's so
weird and the balls are regular so weird
you regular you what great question the
balls were regular yeah would you rather
your partner wake up every morning and
belch directly in your face or fart
directly in your face Bel every morning
fart fart in your face belch is
disgusting Dave's breath is way worse
than any other body part for sure parts
are so disgusting farts are the funniest
thing me and Duncan were farting
yesterday for 3 hours on the floor
laughing so hard I think farts are I do
not think that there is something
funnier than farts fart comedy is good I
have the complete opposite I think farts
are not funny and I'm like strict about
it I think farts I have a friend so to
be strict about a thing that's like a
bodily function too they're farts are
not comedy if you heard my mom's farts
they have word they're
like they're like that my mom's yeah my
mom has ass Flappers the ass slappers
are on she it's like I'm like is it I'm
always trying to figure out is because
of like her ass is big and it's like the
meat hitting like the meat of the cheek
loose over the years imagine pushing out
for 60 years so it's like it's crazy you
can hear them from like they have vowels
like they're like
R I always say the chandelier Shake in
the neighbor's house it's the best or
when like you know some I farted the
other day and my feature was like that
was a shower fart but you're not in the
shower that's like a huge issue yeah and
I was like that's so funny that you know
that's a shower fart that is a shower
fart it grosses you out I just don't
think it's funny or a form of
entertainment she is fart level though
so she's traumatized is it the
smell I just think that like low brow
people think farting is funny and I
don't and that's it like there's nothing
more I want to know how that's possible
okay Ian on the plane farts and he
becomes Enemy Number One like it's a
huge issue for everybody on the plane
okay and it's like people are literally
like looking at the my our producer and
is like is do you know him and he has to
lie and be like I don't know this guy is
he farting loudly no they're always you
can fart on a plane planes are a great
place to fart you can't he I yelled at
people for that I turned around and I
said you don't have to say who you are
but whoever is farting right now you
stop it you did not do that yes what are
you supposed to do yeah you got to fart
it's if you're stuck there with if it's
like open Tunnel and someone just keeps
going it's on I'll fart on stage I'll be
crop dusting the audience the whole time
too I fart on airplanes and it's a
problem for myself cuz it does it is
contained so it comes up suck when
you're like ooh this is obviously me
you're like oh this didn't spread out at
all I hate when I smell one on the plane
though I do I do not like when you're
taking a out of one I've told this story
before but Esther and I were on a plane
together going to Montreal and there was
a guy had [__] his pants in front of us
and it was one of the funniest things
that have ever for sure we thought it
was a kid it was like a whole there was
a whole there was pictures video like a
man definitely sh his pants in front of
us for a long flight everyone was like
though everyone was talking about it not
to him but like around him about it you
could smell out of water [__] it was bad
you know what's the worst is when you
step in dog [__] and then you smell like
[__] the whole day it's so like that
there's no worse feeling I hate poop but
I think farts are I think she starts
judging you she's ew poop poop is bad no
I mean I hate smelling like poop I hate
smelling poop I hate smelling like poop
scary but when somebody goes in the
bathroom and stall next you and they sit
down they just let out like a that
doesn't get you a little bit my I'm
telling you my mom's always doing too
like every time I've gone to the
bathroom my mom she's just like farting
so loud she like had a roommate for this
this Retreat she was going on and she
was just farting so loudly the whole
time and that her roommate like didn't
think it was funny at all but it was
like too late she already EST one my
best friends I'll fart and I like look
at her and she's like she'll just keep
talking I'm like how is that possible
she doesn't want to like encourage it
she doesn't she just says like I don't
think it's funny and I'm in the middle
of a sentence and I keep going but I'm
like crying laughing there's something
about it that is like do you fireart in
front of the guy that dumps you all the
time never but that's the other thing is
I realized that's unacceptable cuz I
think farts are great and he thought
they were not funny at all and I was
like like he would fart for you oh he
would fart and it was okay he well you
know how men just can't not fart we
cannot fart we have a magical butthole
that can do that but he would fart and
be like oh sorry I farted and I'd be
like also every guy I know and have ever
dated has had to take a [__] basically
on the first date at our house at my
house every time I can't tell you my my
one boyfriend that I lived with for 3
years he like forgot to flush his toilet
the first time I went to his house like
who does that and he was a very clean
guy so it was weird did you say
something where you like oh I was like
did you leave that [__] [__] in here
yeah of course I said something I was
like are you kidding me but he also I
saw I've told this story too but his mom
like was staying with us once and she
came out of the shower and she was
wearing a robe and she didn't realize
what she was doing but she like lifted
her robe up to show us like she was
talking about like how her niece is like
a Bo and lifts her skirt up but she
didn't realize that she was completely
Bush out her vag was like in our and it
was like one of the craziest things
that's ever happened I had a mom walk in
while I was blowing her son oh my not
that bad old high school that's pretty
bad he I I was sitting on the couch and
he was like facing me here and I was
blowing him and she
came M yeah I think a mom walking in I'm
kind of like that's fine but then he did
a sumersault he got so scared when he
heard her he got so scared when he heard
her coming down the stairs that he
flipped out did a Som over me so I was
just standing there like oh no facing oh
how about okay when I when I was the the
guy lost my virginity too lived in the
basement of his house and um he would
pull his he wore saggy pants and he
would pull them just pull his penis out
the front to have sex with me but I
would be fully naked a fully naked
14-year-old with nipple rings on this
water bed and his laundry was the
laundry room was like across the hall
and his mom just had a curtain not a
door for him so he'd hear her coming
down the stairs and he would just hop
off and pull his pants up and then I'm
just fully naked oh yeah I'm just a
naked girl he's fully clothed I'm just
totally nak that's [__] yeah I've
definitely had that how does this help
in any way I also hate that now I'm like
I know that you're hard just talking to
your mom which is crazy you know what I
mean like you're just like they're like
blue balling talking to their mom yeah
I'm like would you rather have two long
teeth like a beaver or no teeth at all
two beaver teeth I would like that
immediately let's get me now I almost
out have I like big teeth I love big
teeth it's a sign of a
sociopath would you rather listen to an
annoying laugh for 24 hours straight or
get tickled for an hour tickled for an
hour 24 hours of anything will make me
lose my mind I don't want to get tick
I'm also not ticklish you oh trick
question you're not ticklish you are
psychotic I know well I got tickled it
got you got tickled out of you well when
you're not tickled as a kid you're not
ticklish really no I don't know if
that's true it's not a sensation have
you ever gotten a massage like a
professional massage yes all the time
and there's never been any moment when
they like they where you're like oh oh
for sure yes for sure definitely it
exists the refle I'm not a dead between
your legs it gets a little tickly like
if they your start raping
me oh when he starts eating my ass then
I'm like whoa I did go to a late night
one once where the guy was like and I
was like oh of course this was that was
I friends with you then yeah you said he
was like opening your butt opening my
[__] yeah yeah that's always crazy
but I was like oh my God they massages
24 hours I was like that's so awesome I
would so fault for that too I was like
this is incred wanted them to [__] me
before like I've been in a massage at a
place that I know it's not like a rub
and tug but it's like it could be and
I've been like bro you could he got so
aggressive with me that I was like this
dude could [__] me right now and I would
pay for it I do think that they are
always down yeah but you can't you're a
woman it just isn't done yeah isn't that
crazy or just like get a wooden thing
and shove it in me you've just riled me
up to an insane get a get a gacha that's
a dick shaped get a goddamn dick gacha I
can I will never do a m masseuse again
I'll never do it's been I'm just like
I'm literally being Harvey Weinstein I
don't get any movie out of it I know
that's like discrimination but I'm not
it's not
discrimination like well male masseuses
like they need work too well massage a
guy yeah what if you knew the guy was
gay gay people sometimes can be more
touchy than I actually just don't it's
like not almost sometime for me I just
don't want a man touching me it doesn't
matter his does this bother you would
you ever would you ever role play with
your significant others like M masseuse
and client I think I I think that I mean
just to get him to give me a massage
yeah totally yeah yeah you're totally
getting blown after this I promise just
finish the massage no like you massage
him and then he's like whoops sorry
that's awesome I want to do that right
now yeah that sounds great I love
massage porn a lot same really oh yeah
it's the best yeah where the massage
comes in he's like oh you got a lot of
work to do and then he starts [__]
her what are we doing in the gay World
it'll be like it'll be like a couple's
Mass you gay oh yeah wow super I have a
gatar like a heat seeking missile and I
had you guys switched that's what was
going on I F get G for me at all not
even a [__] ha my guy interesting I
get super straight from you and gay from
you cuz he's trying to get guys yeah I'm
gay you're killing it every gay guy
wants to bang yes the people that he get
I mean the guys [__] yeah yeah no really
there no like he doesn't know how to act
this is so funny they're the hottest
people plus he speaks French so they're
just creaming their pants whoa I don't
care about French look at you men I
don't give a [__] about I love when
there's a straight gay guy I love I
don't like if a guy like tries to pull
out French on me I'm get the hell out of
here I go wait why do you speak French
my f my word French Moroccan oh my God I
mean I want to I'm not even getting a
little what do we got for Sho wear
really nothing's giving it away a guy
pulling out his second language to try
to impress me is never going to happen I
would never do that if you like we're at
dinner and you just start speaking we go
to you take me to a French restaurant
Julian and you just start speaking full
I'm like I'm out I'm got go to the
bathroom I leave I I did that with him
and I was like this is how he gets the
guys as listen as a friend very
impressed you get it out too
easily no it's trying too hard I get it
out if a guy says CIA we're done dude
yeah it's over this is you guys I don't
like this if the guy's hands are weird
do you want to know what she do you want
to know what she said was bad if a guy's
wearing shitty like sandals like gross
shoes I'm done she was like that's
horrible I'm like there's a specific
type of not flipflops I ha flip flops
there's like a there's like flipflops
maybe you're like a Surfer something's
happening okay there's a there's a thing
that could be attached to it there's a
type of [__] sandal that is like flat
they're like Jesus sandals there's like
a toe it's like one toe is covered and
then it's a straight line I'm not
interested I can't get on board with
this she was like you're crazy I'm like
this is not crazy that does sound gross
but you can change a person's shoes no
you that's they are they are you a
little bit of a shoe but like Esther a
guy's wearing those and you're fine I
can do AA I can Crush AA no but Tas kind
of came back in there's like a specific
I'm telling you it's like it's a you're
talking about guy who it's like leather
yeah and you're like and you've only
seen him and his face is kind of cute so
you're like oh okay and then you go
you're not hot let me tell you the shoe
that you'll hate look up that shoe that
shoe is you cannot bounce back there's a
thing in your head that thought that was
okay that I can't get on board with
nothing what about guys who have Pat who
have leather Chelsea boot but but almost
like a pointed toe like I I used to like
gay that's now I know you're gay that
[__] I can't like this is like I cannot
I'm like I don't know what is going on
in your life that allowed you to do this
I just think we're all getting icked out
too easily I think it's a I think it's a
cultural problem I think that we just
talk about it now if I saw that shoe I'd
be like we're never going to be friends
I know that about us yeah it's like if
somebody's like it's too far of a leap
like I I've had guys that are just like
they're very like smart or funny like
something else is happening so their
brains aren't thinking about shoes their
shoes aren't bad but they're still
sneakers or something they're not like
they're not good but it's like oh I'm
just going to get him Jordans or I'm
just going to like I'll just like fix
that a little bit that is that is a
different breed of that is a man he's
that's not for me that is that is
Russell Brand that is guy who's like
that is Russell Brand that is Russell
Brand what if it was like a hot Italian
guy that nope no that's like it's it's a
guy who has like a ponytail and he like
wears linen all the time and he like
thinks that he like it's not okay te he
says stuff like oh I want you to be a
part of my tribe you know certain Jared
Leto is worn those and I but listen I
only like Jared Leto as Jordan Catalano
and I've been on record saying that over
and over again and Jordan catalana would
not have been caught dead in those I've
seen him in real life once I saw him at
Cafe Gratitude are you the same size as
him he's small right no he's big he was
sitting I think he's big though but I
was like that is the most beautiful
person I've ever seen it was like weird
yeah but as as Jordan Catal I'll an
abusive person but if they have that
shoe it's done and there's and there's
I've dressed men like I've had men that
I'm like okay you need my help I've
taken men shopping like I've done that a
bunch of times that's a fedora that's
aora it's a choice that like should
never like it's and and you don't want
to change someone who dresses like that
the type of person they are and it's
like I don't even want to in general any
kind of flat hat I don't like maybe I am
part of the I will [__] and a cowboy hat
I like hats yeah I like what about the
brim like La ones that are like oh I
call those like like a famous dad I
always go do you have a famous Dad yes
but now everyone has them now cuz it's
like a famous D hat for real not the
giant one but yeah kind of like now
everyone has those but it was like it
was just sort of like oh you would have
to have the confidence of a famous
father oh yeah no I'll the thing with
Hats is I do like a cowboy hat but
beyond cowboy hat like a big hat it's
they're so inconvenient that it's like
dude I'll do a trucker hat I'll five
panel I but I like I like baseball hats
that's unacceptable that man's
disgusting okay yeah that's a horrendous
man really yeah get rid of that W I like
cowboy hats but I like um I like a
baseball hat you like cowboy hats mhm I
like a baseball hat I like the you know
the Imagine Todd and a cowboy hat he
wears them all the time Todd and I do
hallucinogens there's a there's always a
cowboy hat in love cowboy hat with a
bolo what are we doing that's great
that's a lot Bel Buckle I like a nice
belt buckle oh my God Jordan I have a
guy for you who is it is it Ian fance
because we're not going to date and he's
already my podcast do you think Ian
wants to date you or no Ian has the the
the he he's also anxiously attached
which I'm not attracted to so we're
we're both codependent yeah you're both
the same yeah and when somebody I become
avoid it when somebody's like that like
I become like it's so cruel it's so
cruel the way it works it's actually I
remember dating a guy where I was really
dating down and I and he was kind of
like not like he was being he wasn't
being rude to me but he like he would
say no to me sometimes and I be like
he's not choosing me like triggered my
not choosing thing so I thought he was
like dating other like not into me or
whatever and then he wrote me like a
love letter and I was like I'm out he
wrote me like a long DM I was like wo
I'm out like I I misread it I thought
you were being aloof you were just like
managing your feelings about me and the
minute I knew it was into me I was like
goodbye and guys don't get mad at me
this is we're talking about how crazy we
are this is not like I feel like there's
so many people that hear so many people
are talking about what they like so many
women are talking about what they like
now that guys get so mad like well what
are we supposed to make I don't know be
yourself and then find someone that
likes that one honestly and I don't even
think it's about like we're being too
picky anymore like what you to go back
to what you said I think it's just a
matter of like people have to remember
that they just have to find the person
that matches that personality cuz like
like like Jordan you have every right
for someone to laugh at a fart joke
right like not be annoyed at it you know
we all have that right to want this is
such a cute little speech you have the
right it's true though I know it is but
also think okay so if I met this like
amazing guy and he had he was wearing
those sandals I would be able to he
would come to me okay if this was the
right guy for me and he would go my
luggage was stolen these are [__]
disgusting I'm an idiot like he would he
would be like I was thinking about them
and like Johnny Depp and you're like
dude no these are like orando BL you
know and he'd be like oh yeah it's like
Orlando Bloom like I love kitty Perry
Orlando Bloom could not come near me and
I know he's like it's there just
something he's a Mady dude he does look
like he chokes her though doesn't he
they are such a peculiar celebrity
couple to me like they're lasting long I
don't know how they met they don't have
like there's a picture of them meeting
really she's um I feel like she's more
masculine than him so she takes the like
where is their crossover like she's like
a bubblegum pop star so is she's like a
bit she's funny he's a serious actor
who's your number one celebrity Crush
yeah like if you could have him at any
year any age any whatever I used to say
leave shriber but I got over him because
someone told me he suck someone was like
no mine is Vince vaugh oh really I see
him sometimes any he's around he's
orbiting he's orbiting okay well he's
around seen him in I've like literally
met everyone you all of mine and I'm
like no it's like Jenner it's Kendall
Jenner Chris Jenner um so I I know who
mine is now I'm sure there so oh you
know what it is is Kendall Roy speaking
of Kendall the character Kendall Roy on
succession I will character I will I
will that is listen to me another if you
were my close friend you would I would
think that you were doing a bit right
now because I find that character
disgusting to be so repugnant shut up I
was excited you know what I like about
you you gear up and I don't know which
so F kend we we would watch it me and my
roommates and he would come on I'd be
like oh his this slope shoulder ass
[__] goober and they'd be like Jesus
look it doesn't get better as the
seasons go on but season one like ruined
my life like I was obsessed he's so hot
I needed Dave to like do an impression I
would rather [__] the culan the C I
honestly think the dad's hot shut up
give me the dad over this guy is so like
powerful he's mean cuz he's mean to us
know you think this guy this is evidence
that we never in competition with no
women are competing the hottest thing
like I can't even it's he's so hot to me
well I did watch normal people did you
see that yeah did you watch it yeah and
I thought the guy and Todd would like
pop in be like what are you watching and
they'd be like this this guy so ugly I
was like he's so hot but only because he
was being like aloof and mean to her it
was in the character He's the hottest
person in the entire world no he's so
that dude's the hottest man life he's
bring he's so hot and he's very aloof in
it and that like
like or was with her really that's
really look up young Vince Von just
throw up a young Vince Von I will freak
out this man is so his whole way of
being is the I saw him it was weird I
saw him at a party and I and I was like
in I was standing next to the
conversation and I just didn't feel like
talking to him it was weird I didn't
think that would happen I catall him on
accident I mean not on accident but I
saw him and he was like I was like hey
I'm a huge fan yeah he was so hot and
like clay
pigeons I get it you know who was slept
on I think Brendan Fraser you're young
yeah yeah but then I I can't unsee the
whale I'm I'm done I the whale was not
acceptable yeah that triggered
acceptable unacceptable he seems like a
really great guy though so I do I see
that but doesn't he seem too oh [__] he
was hot doesn't he cry too much I my the
guy I lost my virginity to and dated for
years looked exactly like young Brandon
Frasier huge dick um Jordan thank you so
much for being here today I've had the
best time ever I feel like we'll have a
reveal from you later about about what a
gross disgusting celebrity that you
think is hot that no one else thinks is
hot I mean everything I think is hot
everyone thinks is gross Internet kendle
is [__] up yeah I guess she did is it
the actor or the character just the
character was weak it was sad did you
like that he was like bad that he I we
more on more on this next week um Jordan
where can people see more of you I have
a half FL FL flower on YouTube it's so
funny I watched it like it I'm on the
fence about it I thought it was edited
weird but you like the jokes yeah I like
the jokes I love it just it's so
fast-paced it's just like I'm like it's
she like that was the part of the
editing I didn't like it is fast-paced
yes good it's really I'm doing a slower
Pace now so I'm like whatever you're
doing is the thing you like doing so
look out for a new hour coming up in a
while but I'm on J my tour dates are
Jordan Jensen comedy.com I'm on all the
[__] um except for Twitter Jordan Jensen
LOL stop and I have a podcast called B
and in with Jordan thanks for having me
we'll see you guys next week than for
[Music]
coming